[Music]
making coffee chris is making coffee he
wanted me to tell you
well there's no one on the air so it's
fine
this is
god see why you're so wrong and let me
tell you why
because that's just why it's so great
blueberries that's why blueberries are
so great because
the tasty ones come at you and explode
in your mouth
while sometimes you get some bitter ones
and that's like a special treat it makes
the whole experience better
bye sorry guys my friends were having an
argument what were the best
fruits and it's blueberry and that's it
i don't want to talk about it
you guys ready or what dude i have a
white cloth we're just clapping this
whole thing up
oh god all right hold on let me get my
guys hold on one second we're just
setting up you know
i honestly think bananas are better oh
bananas but
don't even enter the chat dude
and bananas don't enter the chat i don't
like any
i don't like any fruit with casing dude
like pineapples and
peppers are great but they lose because
it's like oh what's in here and it's
just pineapple not [ __ ] cash
they have a spiky [ __ ] thing like
it's [ __ ] but it keeps it fresh if
anything it's like you're getting a
fresh bite whereas the blueberries are
already kind of sitting out in the air
just like picking up particles and
bacteria and stuff
but that's what all food does anyway
right i don't know yeah
well what i'm saying is that the
highlight of a banana is that it's in
the casing
the highlight of a banana yeah if that's
that's a highlight the highlight should
be how it tastes
and it's a really good food like if i'm
really hungry in the middle of the night
it's a good food for that good food in
the morning it's healthy it's a
versatile food you're saying first off
you can bring it okay i'll give you that
you can bring it somewhere
you can't like bring a handful of
blueberries what's up guys welcome to
flex avenue we're
uh we keep thinking we're gonna do a new
game but we don't because we actually
kind of like this game and to be honest
it takes two and we're the two that it
takes
so we beat some bees we beat uh toolbox
and we beat
uh a vacuum cleaner so let's see what's
next
come on down to flex avenue and join us
and remember life rips
i got the shirt on and the pants dude
sorry watch out for my quads but wow so
[ __ ] that it was on the left side and i
had to lean over like this
but if you want to check out quads there
we go
it's all good dude give me a wedgie
no no you're gonna poke my butt no
go to the side though your butt does
look good enough
lean a little bit down and these shorts
for whatever reason
fit no i have a back seat dude yeah i
noticed that i have a back i noticed
that i
that i uh have a back seat the other day
when i re-watched a little bit of the
twitch
and i turned around i had a back seat
johnny's got a back seat dude
i got one of those back seats in the
back of a station wagon where the
sometimes you look and there's just like
someone sitting on the back of it facing
the other way
yeah what do i have a slide
oh okay you gotta goop it up remember
goop it up bunny it up dude
sap it up that's what it is sap it up i
like poop though
sap it up and your boy will flame it
there we go
your boy keeps it nice and flamey i
definitely keep it nice and flamey
oh okay oh
honestly are these boss so russian no so
like
these boss
we need to explode the other ones dude
oh dude unreal man i already i'm already
mad dude
i have a limit you know what i mean
i get angry and have a limit anger
i have a limit to where i can only get
so far and then i
oh my god i blew my lid
i blew my [ __ ] lid and then and then
oh
oh god dude come on he disintegrated
johnny disintegrates
i know dude somebody's like you gotta
leave i know i'm leaving dude i know
i'm leading i am trust me i'm leaving no
i'm not a bad leader it's sexy the way i
lead
okay jump there we go
and then just relax i know i get a
little bit you get jumpy and it's fine
yeah but just relax
you make the move and then you relax
yeah right so jump it
jump dash jump and then relax right
there's no rush what do we have a
meeting we don't
jump dash jump just relax
to the glowing thing jump dash jump
it's all good relax relax so you didn't
relax enough but it's fine but you
didn't relax enough
okay that could have been trouble right
sure but you didn't relax enough but
it's fine we did it
so jump dash jump right on that thing
it's okay
you got it and relax no here we go dude
now slide down the
baby good job come on don't do that wow
we're team if you do that that's
[ __ ] that's mutiny
i think that's us with that kid oh cute
oh my god imagine cow playing soccer
okay i know
i know it's like us
the what the picture oh that's very cute
yeah i haven't taken any
professional photos of us yet you me
we haven't taken any pictures like
family photos since kyle's been alive
we haven't no oh yeah because of the
pandemic yeah we gotta do that
oh no dude look at how many this is a
swarm
so we learned stuff too during this game
it's a swarm okay
now it's gonna relax
oh oh oh oh
wow that was way way okay here we go
another swarm
i think you might have spoke too soon
sweetheart i talked like that
died no but because i was instructing
it's hard to instruct
well they say that those who can't no
but i can do both okay look
we'll cut that out from the highlight
room here we go cody get some sap on
this one come on cody
oh dude look at why would you be looking
at me i mean look at what's going on
what's that like seeing your face over
where you're
waiting that's very sweet that's very
sweet when you looked at me i looked at
you and i missed it and i'm pissed off
at that
previously on chris's life i got a
[ __ ] on me and then back to the game
okay now do you understand what you have
to do
do you don't do the meme face
do you understand okay so here we go you
gotta do it for real though
okay i'm having trouble it's all good
where am i shooting
but you know how i say who's looking do
that yeah
now now we're going sideways right and
that's bad
because we're just
okay that's good
keep doing that and and if we get hit it
spins around so if we get hit
stop shooting right
okay now we gotta go this way
keep going there we go we gotta go
through there well what happened did you
just replace your brain
honestly what just happened you you just
how did you do that
were you [ __ ] with me no i honest to
god
was pressing the red button oh jesus
look at the screen look at my screen
what do you think you have to do
what are those
oh okay now whoa babe
she's good now now she's all good you
could go right right because there's
none over there
no i'm just a mirror is a mere
suggestion
you can drive no i can't drive because
you like to have a stick all
oh this is like a real car argument car
argument
like we're arguing about a car like when
two people are driving
yeah oh how are you guys here yeah
they're bringing it back that's fun
that's funny but this is a lack of death
situation so
yeah somebody said don't ask for advice
on the twitch screen who the [ __ ] you
think i have ninja
somebody said ninja isn't the top
streamer uh actually you know it's
actually funny you say that because
ninja isn't the top streamer anymore
he's still [ __ ] good right
oh nick marks who are my nick merc
thanks what do you say she said good job
kristin
that's sweet oh sweet a friend of mine
wow okay come on all right let's move it
forward
it's lit now there we go
oh look at the mushrooms that grow
whoa oh wow the mushrooms are beautiful
they're
blowing the dark i have a question for
the
twitchers oh is that
twitchers it's people's twitch people on
twitch in the chat
twitter is racist how much would you
guys pay to
watch him on mushrooms do mushrooms
dudes
in my savings i can't people i can't be
bought
i can't be bought 200k somebody says
wow there's a price for everything
sweetheart honestly 50 billion
follow the green thing oh yeah you're
close just turn around
you just this one walks into walls with
this video game
come on you can see where i am you know
but do you see i'm trying to go towards
you and i'm just kind of running into
so keep going forward just
moving forward is always the thing so
just
it's a way no it's all good but this is
a video game so moving forward is the
thing
but do you see i'm moving forward but
i'm going sideways that's fine so keep
exploring
just keep exploring guys i'm sorry
whoa
whoa cool
imagine my dad playing this game he'd be
like the [ __ ] i think he'd be cute
it would be cute he wouldn't understand
that no he'd laugh with that you get
swept up in it look if you're doing the
build laughing
your dad really is just the best human
on the planet
boom shoot me out interstellar
am i going the right way if i go forward
do you see me
i'm working on me here kind of we're
nowhere
i know but look i know it takes two but
oh yeah so hit x
okay i don't know whoa look at that
thing
all right and because i stopped and
helped you
[Music]
hit x yeah you got to keep moving it up
there we go x when you hit it
x when you hit it and i'll just wait for
you on my piece but i don't know where
i'm going
well not down okay hit the
x and go up up up x yeah
okay there we go now get into that one
yeah dude when you get there hit x
up in that one dude now check this out
where are we you
might want to brace yourself look try to
get on the beam i'm on the beam
get on the beat look at that thing
[Music]
nothing will happen here would be nice
catfish
whoa this is gorgeous
the same aeropress over and over again
that's from the movie congo
i'm a film buff let's do some rapid fire
questions while we're here i don't
you you just fell off the fish you can't
even do this game
and you want to do rapid fire questions
you'll die dude it's too hard
what is your favorite no fruit
blueberry what i already told you that
before the stream started what was your
favorite
subject in school i didn't have one too
[ __ ] all that lunch what's your favorite
i don't want to do this purple oh
my god um what's your favorite thing
about our door
oh man he's the best he is really well
behaved and very funny gets the joke
dude and he also i was bonking my head
last night making him laugh and today he
woke up and started bonking his head
like he remembered
you know but i could never pick one
favorite thing of our son because
everything about him
i meant good shape in this world oh
somebody said lay off the claws
you're saying i'm in bad shape
because you're you're [ __ ] faced
honestly let's see how much you've had
i've had a half of a workout like this
and you're real at your limit
your [ __ ] face what if you went what if
you stopped drinking and you looked in
the mirror and you just had like
mascara running down you're just like oh
my god it really [ __ ] up
remember that video that when we were
first dating like a year into
dating and i you picked me up yeah that
was the first time you saw me drive
yes and it was hilarious i still have
that video
i do is it bad to put it up
i don't give a [ __ ] it's hilarious
you're the funniest drunk ever but also
i'm so drunk i did a joke about how you
were walking into the thing and looking
in the mirror and you just kind of
i want you to take it in and then you
could talk about your story
take it in and you just remember
but take it in right take it
it's all good but we gotta do this
somebody said chris wants to play and
kristen wants to talk lol yeah
yeah that's pretty much that's how it
goes i don't do these side games the
video game side games i don't do
let's get on these though
that looks like a shooting range i don't
want to do it i want to play the whole
game i want to beat it is there just a
top
part of twitch whoa is this a game
is there a tar a talk part of twitch
yeah it's called just chatting
where are you going this is foreign
how do we just i want to get out of here
and just keep playing that well i
figured it out
did i oh did i go backwards
what's going on it offends me that you
do that do i have bad
senses of where i am just
go there straight nice
you see the blue thing right that's the
thing that i keep forgetting about well
don't
how about this don't forget about it
anymore oh okay just go to the blue
thing always because i'm the blue thing
you're the green thing and i know that
because whenever i'm lost i look for it
and i see it and then i go get you oh so
you're admitting that you get lost too
no when i get when i lose you is what i
meant to say
this is hard dude i can already tell i'm
not gonna like this one at all
why are there so many bees
i know but there's so many when there
weren't any in the first two stages and
now there's so many
change up the animals and insects dude
we fought a [ __ ] toolbox in a vacuum
that was fun to [ __ ] these these are
annoying
you could make a game oh
uh my video game would be so simple and
so bad
but people would honestly probably lost
me for it
people would log me for it
log means like i know it okay i can't
believe they
said it that people would log me if i
make a video game
you don't you don't you don't think that
i make a good video game all the way out
you literally just said i would make a
video game and it would be so bad so
about this
people would get it and they would laud
me people like that it's like every
eric roberts movie i watch him you bring
up
aircraft i wonder why i bring him up
because he's great i think he's just
like such a perfect example of the kind
of guy that you like
he's attractive yep yeah a bad actor
okay well he's a bad movie all right but
he thinks he's great
okay i can't argue with like [ __ ]
almost all of those except for the
bad actor dude that guy kills it zap
them up
we sap them up dude let's set them up
dude they're coming close like they know
like they don't like like we don't know
to set them up
that's the [ __ ] ego on these
[ __ ]
babe do you know what projecting is
yeah you better project the [ __ ] sap
out of these bees before
these look this mind your [ __ ]
beeswax
it's cool right when i say that all
right very cool check it out
hey bees you can't believe you're trying
that
very cool right oh my god i love these
guys i'm an action movie guy
like you know um okay i'll do more
we know there'll be more bees you better
believe it
i i already used that one but but did
you
yeah i used two that was one of them you
forget already
and you said you like it oh but do i
have all sides i'm pretty angry
somebody said what's happening
that's funny oh should i be mine that i
came up with
your what my one joke that i came up
with they're so bad she has the words
you have one you don't remember it
there's two lines oh dude there's a
beetle
a giant beetle i knew about that because
i i know a lot about
what does a witch it is not time for
these kinds of jokes
what does a witch make her flu medicine
okay you can say it now i know the
answer
okay now back to killing this giant
beetle and also dude pretty good
no that's bad sap up the grades
well think about what the word great
might mean oh my god
i don't mean to be me but g-r-i-t-e well
i'm boycotting completely i'm sorry what
did i do wrong you said
think about what great might be don't
give yourself i'm trying not to tell you
what to do that's why
this is you trying not to tell me to do
well i'm saying
think about what great means rather than
the [ __ ] grade
you understand what i'm saying this is
the stuff those are the two options
you say hold on a second the money that
we're gonna spend in therapy
by the end of our lives is going to
somebody said remember your therapy
that's exactly what i'm doing
you say you say i say the greats and you
say what is great and i say
well let's think about what great means
instead of the [ __ ] graves
use your goddamn eyes i would never say
that
would never say you should goddamn i
said you know that you wouldn't say it
to me but you would say that to everyone
else that you know
like a postmates driver you know
something funny about chris that i
didn't know
is that i was always really nice to him
the first year was dating can you get
the grades while you tell the story
that's probably not true sure but is
this what something you like about me
yeah
all right well then why i didn't know
that you um
like your love language is talking [ __ ]
yeah and you like when i touched it
it's like oh yeah it makes you feel
that's weird um i don't know uh heard
well okay well how about this hear this
telling stories during the final bosses
is prohibited it's really hard to
it's really hard to hit these final
bosses
while you're telling a story about a
childhood or whatever
i know you'll do what you want but
please stop the grades
whoa you do you know what dude you're
doing too much you're doing too much
just relax have a good time i put some
lotion on oopsie daisy dude one more
sapping it up dude
once one more sapping it up oh dude he's
doing everything man oh you got those
red rings on oh that's okay dude i can
dodge him and i can jump
oh [ __ ] but i'll tell you this much oh
here comes a red ring but we knew about
it
yeah dude hey dude you're doing way too
much you work [ __ ] seven days a week
what about those weekend days huh you
gotta have some time to chill with your
lady
[ __ ] babe bring him over here you gotta
chill with your lady
boom oh no take a relax
i hope this is the boss because
oh this is the boss i think i spoke too
soon
let's go have you lost your voice like
the tragic accident
how would you get your points across
all the time oh dude that's where the
cult comes in for real what do you mean
they know what i want
this game's cool dude i'm sorry i don't
like it
got her we have a draw she might not be
done so we're probably getting her
you pay for that again dude oh that this
is good you got to get her head
i think i don't even know her oh the
chain the chain you gotta get the chain
you got the [ __ ]
oh
i get it
[Music]
she's probably like oh you shouldn't
have done that and then she comes back
we did it right okay that was good
we did it oh nice
oh that fat beat helped us
i knew it was gonna be the cut scene too
yeah yeah we're done
oh are we yeah
no this is a cutscene
wow look at that that's like the movie
blown away with kurt russell
remember that movie babe everyone
remembers that movie
he jumps off the dock nice dude
hell yeah man we did it that's great
we should stop there that's a great
stopping place let's
end the twitch stream with a compliment
okay
well you're saying both compliment me
i can go first i honestly i'm really
impressed with my thought with my thighs
lately the way i've been working out and
it's really
they're really it's really pretty
okay um i will do you
here we go you honestly tried to give me
your controller a few times
and i said no you do it and
what you did because of your
determination
your prowess your steadfast sad badness
steadfastness
you're just intuitive yeah thank you
you're welcome and also kill here
[Music]
you're like making it so real yeah
okay go ahead
well thank you steadfastness
no way dude come on you're amazing dude
you're great
squirrels great guys we thought the bees
weren't so bad
all right thanks guys thanks for
watching all right we gotta finish let's
finish this cut scene and then we'll see
what's up
you also have great thighs thank you
to me we're still alive don't do
anything crazy please
like what don't do your usual racial
slurs
don't they're still watching don't
they're still watching don't tell them
how calvin's a hologram
do not we're still watching
[Music]
you